euh pour bien comprendre comment se pose
le problème aux États-Unis il faut avoir
à l'esprit que la législation sur
l'avortement dépend des États fédérés et
non de l'État fédéral et le schéma
classique de nombreuses questions
juridiques est alors de savoir si telle
loi d'un État est conforme au principe
constitutionnelle de la Fédération
l'arrêt d'obs qui a mis fin à 49 ans de
protection constitutionnelle du droit à
l'avortement a pour origine un procès
euh intenté dans le Mississippi et dont
l'objet était de déterminer si une loi
interdisant les interruptions de
grossesse avant le seuil de viabilité
était conforme à la Constitution et
l'affaire s'inscrivait dans une
stratégie relativement nouvelle de la
part des mouvements anti-avortement de
proposer des lois clairement contraires
à la jurisprudence en vigueur afin de
remettre en cause le droit à
l'avortement alors en 2018 sous
l'impulsion des lobbyes anti-avortement
l'État du Mississippi avait adopté une
loi qui interdisait la plupart des
interruptions de grossesse dès la 15e
semaine d'aménoré ce qui était anti
onstitutionnel car contraire aux arrêts
RW versus W 273 et plan Parenthood VKC
de
1982 contre toute attente la Cour ne se
contenta pas de modifier le cadre
constitutionnel mais opta pour un
renversement total de jurisprudence un
fait qui est très rare aux
États-Unis où la continuité du droit est
un principe
essentiel mettant en avant une approche
originaliste de la Constitution la Cour
a statué que l'avortement ne pouvait
être un droit protégé donc le cadre
établi par r versus weight qui
n'autorisait pas les États à interdire
l'avortement avant le seuil de viabilité
et limiter leur capacité à restreindre
son accès tout au long de la grossesse a
donc aujourd'hui totalement
disparu alors la question de
l'avortement a par conséquent été
renvoyée aux seuls état fédéré qui sont
maintenant libres de le protéger de
l'interdire et de le réglementer à leur
guise alors dans les grandes lignes
quelle est la situation à l'échelle
nationale d'abord l'avortement est
désormais interdit dans 14 États l'AV se
état ont établi une limite gestationnale
gestationnelle pardon qui va de 4
semaines de grossesse en geéorgie ou en
Caroline du Sud à 16 semaines de
grossesse dans
l'UTA
ensuite dans 5 états la situation est
actuellement incertaine en majorité
parce que des lois adoptées ont été
suspendu temporairement par un juge et
enfin en réaction à l'arrêt d'obs 20
États plus le district de Colombie
c'est-à-dire Washington DC ont établi de
nouvelles protections législatives ou
constitutionnell pour le droit à
l'avortement